the reality of mobile networking means
that the number of file requests can be
just as significant as the size of
requests in other words aim to reduce
the number of image requests not just
the size of image files we call this
problem latency which is the delay
between request and response yeah every
time your browser attempts to retrieve
an image from a website there are
potential delays at every step of the
way between your device and the websites
servers and every one of those delays
can vary significantly and unpredictably
behind all that is the fundamental
problem that data can't travel any
faster than the speed of light yeah I
mean surely Google or someone else could
do something about that the speed of
light you know it's so last century I'm
Cameron like yours that's right up no oh
definitely not at least not in time this
millennium all right whatever whatever
um anyway optical fiber can only achieve
a bit better than half the speed of
light so at best London to California
return trip times for example are around
100 milliseconds performance expert ilya
Grigori cause latency the new bottleneck
thanks them indeed it turns out that for
many modern web pages bandwidth doesn't
matter as much as latency does if you
find that surprising check the
instructor notes for an explanation of
why that is a case the bottom line is a
performance as a fundamental part of a
truly responsive design in practice that
means you need to reduce the file sizes
and reduce the number of file requests
and one great way to reduce the number
of image bytes is to compress them or
reduce the number of images thanks
earlier in this lesson we show you lots
of ways to achieve graphical effects
without image files